i was just hardcore gamestop gme
100 we're going to the moon the gamestop
frenzy
brought many new investors into the
market i just started pounding away
okay buy it buy it it keeps going up and
up and up and so i'm getting excited
nearly seven million people downloaded
the eight most popular trading apps
including robinhood in january
that's more than double the previous
month but this community of online
investors
existed before gme took off it's been
growing throughout the pandemic
and it lives on social media robin hood
users have been going
crazy for hurts here you go now stack
versus nysc
new highs today that break yesterday uh
gave you a monster winner
youtube channels reddit forums facebook
groups discord chats and tick tock
influencers like taylor price
are all talking trades this community is
meme
culture it's gen z it's millennial and
it's people who don't want to work the
nine to five
the reason i am able to trade full-time
is solely because of the discord group
i got sm energy at 214. so who's a part
of this growing community of traders
seeking and sharing investment
information on social media
and how are the communities helping them
chase the market
hello my name is colin chong i'm 33
years old i'm ceo
of omni group consulting and i'm new to
the investing market
colin chung started trading on january
25th as hype around gamestop was
spreading
and the company's stock was gaining you
know that morning
like 500 and it turned into 800
and as the share price climbed the next
day chung continued to invest
i was able to somehow get a few thousand
dollars in there
i wake up the next morning and it
doubles
but it was at that point that i realized
you know
uh it's very much like gambling chung
has a business background but not an
investment
so for his stock decisions he turns to
social media
i want to talk to you guys about game
stuff why is gme amc still down
will it go back up all the ones that i
used to use linkedin facebook
not so much i'm looking at very much
more real-time functionality
you know uh twitter instagram
tick tock is this a short squeeze and of
course he's watching the market
so this is my triple monitor setup this
is primarily where i'm doing uh
where i'm monitoring the stock market
for the specific stocks that i'm
watching
despite the setup chung isn't
considering making trading his career
i look at it like i'm spending three
thousand dollars
to entertain myself to see if i can make
it grow
that's why chung says after taking out
most of what he needed to cover his
initial investment
he's put the rest of his returns back in
the market
and he's still holding gamestop an
investment that's now costing him
if there's a profit and a payoff at the
end great
if not i just i just want to have a
vested interest
in seeing where this goes because i
think that that the results are going to
be important
here's three reasons why small stocks
may have big potential
20 year old tick tock influencer taylor
price also saw
gains during the gme frenzy her follower
count
hit 1 million but not because she was
buying into the meme stock
i wasn't saying oh oh look at look at
the situation as a buying opportunity i
was looking at it as a learning
opportunity i just made 350 000 on
gamestop
what no way what are you gonna do with
it the first thing that i'm going to do
is set aside 40 percent for taxes
her posts are quick and informative
seeking to explain basic financial terms
and show her followers how to make the
most of their money
your budget truly depends on your
personal lifestyle
75 of my audience is female
and you don't especially see them being
so young like myself
they want to start controlling their own
finances when
maybe in the past their father or their
older guardian that was male had done so
but price didn't set out to be a social
media influencer
she first got interested in finance
taking college courses on the subject
and she says she started investing
because she saw how much money others
were making
this is how bad the market did today and
this is how good i did today
right here people for many of her
successes she says she also had
a lot of busts and realized that she
needed to take a step back to learn some
personal finance fundamentals
when i had this awakening moment about
financial literacy and what school
wasn't teaching us
that is when i said i need to take this
online
three things nobody told you about
before investing in the stock market
price still actively invests she says
social media is good for qualitative
analysis
but should be followed by research and
her posts aim to show that
social media should be acting as
not just giving somebody a fish but
teaching people
how to fish what this is crazy thank you
taylor
hi i'm john bevis and i am 28 years old
and i am a full-time stock trader john
bevis who once held gamestop shares
which he sold before the spike
said his goal is consistency he wants a
monthly paycheck
not a one-time bonus consistent trading
to me
is able to continuously
make your return without risking too
much money
and always limiting your loss
he says consistency is a goal shared by
members of a paid discord chat he's a
part of
the group run by a company called haiku
has roughly 22
000 participants and includes both a
text chat and voice call
yeah i got i got sm energy at 2 14
and now it's at 12 but i sold off at
like 11. the discord group
has benefited me in almost a way i can't
explain
because of the amount of knowledge and
effort and support they put towards
their members
devis started trading full-time about a
year and a half ago leaving his job in
construction which paid him 45 dollars
an hour
so far trading isn't paying him quite as
well he says he's bringing in anywhere
from 800 to 2 000
per month but he says that's enough for
now
i'm not mistaking large vacations or
anything like that
i can travel if i want to but that'll
take time away from me
here trading and that's what i love to
[Music]
do